[Justine] Trackpad is poppin' up!
What's up guys, welcome back.
I'm Grant Thompson, The King of Random,
and I'm iJustine.
And today, we're here to answer a question
from the comments
from eddieg098, who wants to know,
"Would you damage a laptop
if you spilled liquid nitrogen on
the keyboard?"
So Eddie, we're doing
this experiment today for you.
This is for you, Eddie.
So this is a Chromebook. It is an Acer.
We got this on Amazon Prime Now
and it arrived at my place in 15 minutes
when we decided to do this...
-for you guys. Yeah.
-Amazing service. Unbelievable,
and I can't believe it. I'm jealous.
I don't have internet that fast.
[laughter]
But this is going to be exciting.
So we're basically going to make
a Chromebook cake in this cake pan.
Yes, we found a cake pan that
is the perfect size
for our Chromebook.
It just fits very nicely.
And here we got Eddie's comment
sitting down there at the bottom.
And it fits perfectly
in this cake pan.
And oh yeah. A random cake pan,
look at that.
The dimensions are absolutely perfect.
There's like, maybe a quarter inch gap,
on the front and back there.
It was like it was meant to be.
[Justine] It was.
[Grant] Okay, I think it's "Go" time.
I think so, what do we do now!?
-So let's get you over here,
-Okay.
I've got this thermos that we've already
prefilled with liquid nitrogen.
We set this laptop in a cake pan
and that's so we can
keep as much of the nitrogen
around the keyboard as we can.
So I thought it'd be fun, let's go ahead
and play a video of liquid nitrogen,
while we pour liquid nitrogen
on the computer itself.
So fitting.
[Grant on the Chromebook]
-viable idea because I don't want
to waste new technology unnecessarily.--
[snaps finger]
Alright.
So we got our video playing right now.
We've got our thermos full
of liquid nitrogen.
It's time to pour it on the keyboard
and just see exactly how it reacts.
-So, you want to do the honors?
-Yeah. I don't have my gloves on, though.
-Is that bad?
-Um, I don't think you need gloves.
-Okay...
-I think you're good.
-Should I just pour right in the middle?
-Your hands are insured right?
Hah...
[nitrogen sizzling Chromebook]
Nicely done.
So what we see immediately
is you see all the nitrogen skittle across
and it's kind of collected
in the bottom here and...
what's happening is it's boiling off,
but at the same time
it's cooling everything down.
-Is the video still playing?
-Yeah.
Looks like it is. Alright.
Well I say, let's go ahead
and add some more.
Oh yes, that's what I say.
I heard some cracking.
We got Leidenfrost effect happening
on the trackpad right now.
It was bouncing around
like a game of pong.
Try a little bit more right there.
It was kind of fun how that was...
It's like a little hockey rink.
-Okay look at that right there.
-Oh!
Boing.
I think I saw a little flicker
on the scr--
Oh no that was you.
-That's the video.
-I think, I think some of this nitrogen
is flowing down inside the keyboard
but look the screen
is actually still playing.
That's kind of cool.
-Shall we put some more?
-Hehe it's a video
of a phone in a phone in a phone
in a phone in a phone.
[Justine] In a laptop.
[Grant] Phoneception.
Oh! I called it.
This is looking pretty frosty.
You can see how it's changing color.
See how the buttons used
to be black
and now they're
looking a little bit faded.
-[Grant] Oh...
-[Justine] Wow, look at that.
-[Grant] Well, let's toss in some more.
-[Justine] Yes!
Let's go ahead and fill her up.
Let's submerge that thing.
-Oh. Something just happened, it froze.
-Oh. I heard some things.
It's still going.
-[Grant] Alright let's keep her running.
-[Justine] Here you go, Eddie.
Right on the trackpad, maybe.
-Oh baby!
-Whoa!
[Justine] Trackpad is poppin' up!
[Grant] The trackpad just busted right up
off the computer here.
Look at this, it's just peeled right off.
It's peeling itself off. You--
If you ever wondered
what a trackpad looks like underneath,
'cause,  there it is.
This is just an adhesive.
You feel that it's sticky.
-Wow!
-This is like a giant sticker.
So we'll just like set that off
to the side.
-Yeah.
-But the video is still playing.
-And...
-The mouse, it's working.
-Oh it is! You're right, it's still working.
-Like yeah, the cursor's right there.
Even with my gloves on.
-[Justine] Wow
-[Grant] That's kind of fun. Alright, so...
Did you say we need more liquid nitrogen?
-[Justine] This is-- Aww...
-[Grant] It looks to me--
-[Justine] Screen just went black.
-[Grant] Did it?
[Grant] Uh oh. Can we bring it back?
[Justine] I think that...
-might be the end of our lappy-top.
-That might be.
Let's go ahead
and throw the rest of it in anyway.
and freeze this thing completely solid
and then see when it warms back up,
if we can get it to restore.
This looks so cool.
It's completely submerged right now.
-[Justine] Should I keep pouring--
-[Grant] Yeah pour it all in.
[Grant] Pour it all in.
That is beautiful.
So here we are guys.
It's been about five minutes our computer
has been sitting in the liquid nitrogen.
I think it lasted about
like a minute and a half?
-Yeah.
-Before the screen went off.
What's really interesting
is the screen has bent,
it's actually warped and gone concave.
And it's so cold right now,
we can't even close it.
That might even be
because the screen has warped.
Look at Eddie's comment.
Eddie's comment
is soaked right through, look at that.
You can see,
it dries off pretty quickly though.
There's actually nitrogen
inside the keyboard.
-Look at that.
-Wow.
If I shake it, I can get it to drip out.
[Justine] Yeah look,
it's all dripping right there.
[Grant] And my hands are freezing,
-and the buttons are falling off. Ooh.
-What was that?
You know that was, uh...
-the little bottom,
-Oh, it's not important.
Whatever those are,
the little support tabs?
Or support buttons? [FEET]
Those are frozen off. This is really cold.
Do you want to try holding that
for a second?
-Yeah is it gonna be cold?
-Does that feel cold?
-Yeah it feels cold.
-Yeah. Yeah, it's cold, huh?
-Oh gosh! Oh.
-Hahaha. That's amazing.
That's frosty.
So guys, our computer
is legitimately frozen.
I mean, how cold is that?
I mean, it's frozen.
It's cold enough
that we're gathering frost
-on the bottom here, can you see that?
-Yeah.
This is like Elsa's laptop.
Elsa's laptop.
That's right, should I Iet it go?
-Let it go...
-...it's really cold, the keyboard--
-let it go...
-There you go.
[Grant] What I really want to know is,
at what point in time
could we turn it back on?
[Justine] Oh, do you think the laptop
turned itself off?
Or do you think it just stopped working?
It's hard to say, the buttons don't work.
Feel those, those are
frozen solid as well.
[Justine] Yeah, liquid nitrogen is cool.
[laughs]
[Grant] I see what you did there.
So Eddie, an answer to your question
even at this point,
would liquid nitrogen damage a laptop?
Yeah this definitely is damaged.
I-I'd call this very damaged.
The question now becomes, will it survive?
Can we resurrect the laptop?
Can we bring it back to life?
'Cause even after five minutes now,
I can start seeing the warping
ironing itself out.
I think, um, probably
we could even lay this sticker back
on the trackpad here.
-Maybe?
-Hmm.
Who knows. I guess
we're going to find out.
We're going to give this
about 25 minutes to set
so it can warm back up
to room temperature,
press the power button,
and see what happens
Guys we're back. It's been
about 25 minutes now,
and this computer looks like it's had
about enough time to thaw out.
You can even see all the moisture
from the air, all that frost,
is now condensed and turned into water.
[Justine] Look at this.
Which I think the water
is probably more dangerous
than the liquid nitrogen was.
But the other thing I'm noticing
is the screen has almost
shifted back to normal. We--
We press that back into place.
-Oh look at that!
-Click, click, click.
And, uh, so yeah let's just
take a second now.
Let's take some paper towels,
clean this all up,
and then we'll hit the power button
and see if it actually still works.
I've also salvaged this little sticker
that came from the trackpad
and now that it's unfrozen,
well it's thawed out,
I think we can actually
stick it back in place.
So put that right on there
So...
should we plug it in?
-I don't know.
-Is it safe to plug in?
Probably not.
Well...
safety is not my middle name.
Okay, moment of truth.
Let's see if it'll turn on.
Oh my goodness. Check this out.
Something just popped up.
Chrome...
OS system is missing or damaged.
Please insert a Recovery USB.
They probably just damaged the hard drive.
Hmm. Interesting.
So if we ran some kind of recovery system
it looks like theoretically
this would work.
The LCD screen is back.
-The screen looks perfect.
-The screen looks looks great. Yeah.
But see, um, now this warm up, though,
can we close it?
Yeah, the hinges work.
Okay, so that's thawed back out.
This is pretty durable.
I'm quite impressed actually.
So if we give this a few more minutes
to thaw out, perhaps,
we get this thing to boot up again.
Guys you're not going to believe this.
We just downloaded,
put some information on the SD card
and reformatted the computer
and look at this.
We are back in business.
I mean it's kind of hard to tell right now
because the screen is black
but if we bring up a program like YouTube.
Let's go back to Chrome here.
You can see the mouse works.
The trackpad works perfectly.
and we can bring up
my liquid nitrogen video.
[Grant on Chromebook]
Got like a triple flash there,
the camera just turned off.--
[Justine] Wow!
[Grant on the Chromebook]
--camera turned itself off just because
it had a little battery warning--
So the only problem we really had
with this computer was the sticker
for the trackpad peeled off
and once it warmed up
we just glued it back together,
restart the computer, reformatted it,
and everything is working perfectly.
So, will liquid nitrogen
damage the computer, after all?
I think it damages it a little bit?
I mean I'm sure the internals
of this thing,
something bad has happened,
but it's still working.
Alas, it's not an experiment
we want to recommend that you try
but it's very amazing to see how resilient
and how robust even a computer
on the price point of this one,
-and how it swings back.
-Yeah, this was $170.
-Very crazy.
-Can you believe that?
That's less than a phone.
So I think what we need to do
is give this thing away.
Yeah we could sign it.
We should sign it and give away.
That's a great idea!
All you have to do is go down
to our link in the description
to follow us on Instagram. Follow iJustine and TheKingOfRandom on Instagram
and then look for one of our pictures
from our collaboration
and leave us a comment using this emoji.
Comment that emoji, we're going
to surf through it.
We're going to pick one of you randomly
to get our liquid nitrogen frozen
Chromebook,
that apparently still works
as good as new.
I can't believe it.
So there you have it, guys.
You asked us to pour liquid nitrogen
on a keyboard
and that's exactly what we did.
[Justine] We did. And not only did we pour
it onto the keyboard,
but an entire laptop.
And big thanks to eddieg098
for requesting this experiment.
You can go ahead
and check your YouTube inbox, Eddie,
I'm sending 25 bucks.
Oh that's nice!
[laughs]
Oh Eddie, you get a present!
[laughter]
And huge thanks to iJustine
for letting us terrorize her
in her kitchen, today.
Thank you so much for your space.
Hey thanks for giving me
some liquid nitrogen
and the courage to light myself on fire.
Now we just filmed something epic
in her backyard
that you won't want to miss.
I'll put a link down in the description.
That will take you over to her channel.
Go like, subscribe to follow iJustine,
she's amazing.
And thank you for joining us
for this experiment.
We'll be looking for you in the next one.
-Talk to you, then.
-Bye!
Eddie's gonna go shopping...
[laughs]
I'm just like hanging out
so far away from you
'cause I'm just scared
of what's gonna happen.
Hey guys, I want to jump back in
for just a second to invite you
to come follow me on Instagram
I've got a very active page
where I post daily pictures
and stories of behind the scenes
in every day as an adventure.
Just take five seconds right now
to click the link in the description
to come follow me on Instagram
@TheKingoOfRandom and I'll see you there.